ustedes instan a reducir las emisiones a
la mitad A mediados de 2030 para cumplir
ese objetivo de 1,5 grados visto los
últimos movimientos de aumento de
perforación petrolífera en Estados
Unidos o la vuelta al carbón de países
como Alemania ven bajo las actuales
condiciones que este objetivo pueda
cumplirse y Qué consecuencias tendría no
hacerlo
Hola un gusto estar con ustedes esta
advertencia que el reporte nos brinda
sobre que la acción climática y el ritmo
han sido insuficientes está basado una
serie de estudios que muestran que los
impactos adversos del cambio climático
van a intensificarse no y que los
eventos extremos meteorológicos
climáticos se van a volver más generales
y pronunciados con cada incremento de
calentamiento global el reporte reconoce
que ya se han iniciado acciones
climáticas notamos partiendo de cero
pero que las mismas son insuficientes si
no se reduce de manera drástica estas
emisiones va a ser Inevitable superar el
nivel de calentamiento de un grado y
medio el reporte también plantea de que
ya existen opciones probadas disponibles
y que tienen que y que tienen la
posibilidad de poder ser combinadas con
otras acciones de manera de brindarco
beneficios no acciones con la salud los
medios de subsistencia de las personas
reducir la pobreza y el hambre la
energía agua y aire limpios y otra cosa
que me gustaría destacar es que el
reporte plantea que la equidad tiene que
ser parte de la solución ya que quienes
contribuyeron menos al cambio climático
están siendo los más vulnerables a sus
impactos no hay millones de personas
expuestas de seguridad alimentaria
agudas seguridad
hídrica reducida y las personas en áreas
altamente vulnerables tienen hasta
quince veces más probabilidad de morir
por eventos extremos no Y entonces es
importante incrementar la inversión la
inversión tiene que incrementarse en
tres a seis veces y hay opciones
disponibles para aumentar esta
financiación y por otro lado el reporte
también concluye que hay suficiente
financiamiento global para reducir
rápidamente las emisiones y destaca que
los países en desarrollo son los que
requieren esta financiación externa para
satisfacer las necesidades de adaptación
la ventana es chica pero el reporte
concluye que todavía hay oportunidad
para reducir el cambio el calentamiento
global y quedarse del lado seguro del
planeta no junto a todo esto que nos
Comenta vosotros hablan en el informe
además de promover cambios sociales
entre otros ámbitos también en la
alimentación hablan a sí mismo del
aumento de la inseguridad alimentaria
qué supondría este aumento a nivel
mundial si no actuamos de inmediato
exacto y como mencioné hay millones
expuestos inseguridad alimentaria aguda
ya que regiones del planeta en las
cuales hay pequeños productores están
expuestos amenazas climáticas y que los
ponen al borde del límite de su
adaptación no Entonces por otro lado la
acción entonces climática tiene que ser
amplia rápida pero también tiene que
facilitar el compromiso político no la
gobernanza inclusiva es imposible
hacerlo sin cooperación internacional y
por otro lado también es destacar que
estos cambios transformadores van a
tener éxito donde hay confianza donde
todos trabajamos juntos para priorizar
la reducción de riesgo y donde los
beneficios y las cargas sobre todo se
compartan equitativamente
doctora Vera ustedes alertan también de
episodios cada vez más extremos que ya
podemos ver con Nevada récord ahora
mismo en este invierno en California o
las sequías del pasado verano en Europa
pueden estos episodios de lluvias y
nevadas extremas compensar los episodios
de sequía o es una Falsa ilusión
no no no cada evento extremo en cada
región del planeta está hoy siendo
alterado por el cambio climático
influido por las actividades humanas no
estamos en un mundo de uno punto un
grados y que Entonces esto exacerba los
eventos extremos en cada región del
planeta que en cada lugar toma
características propias no por ejemplo
en el caso del sur de Sudamérica que ha
tenido un incremento de los eventos
extremos de lluvia en los últimos 50
años está experimentando una sequía
desde los últimos tres años en las
cuales también se ha atribuido esta
influencia humana la conclusión es que
nos tenemos que adaptar a una
variabilidad climática que ha sido
incrementada por esta influencia humana
y que
la acción de adaptación por ahora ha
sido insuficiente a pesar de que ya he
comenzado